hey everybody and welcome to a skanky
wild ride with stevo we've got big j
ogresson of legion of skanks fame he's a
legendary stand-up comedian and if you
know anything about him you know he
doesn't hold anything back so when we
start talking about the juiciest
scandals in the world of stand-up comedy
you know he's serving up the jews plus
this guy knows so much
he could work for tmz i'm telling you
it's juicy as hell and it's coming at
you from the road of my bucket list tour
and on the road with me on my bucket
list tour right now is my fiancee
lux
and today we walked around alabama
frankly i have no idea how she was able
to walk after the boning i served her
last night it's true baby you really
pounded me yeah and when i bone my girl
you know i've got a serious boner
because i use blue chew tablets what's
that it's a delicious tablet with the
same active ingredient as both viagra
and cialis except it costs just a
fraction of the price and man does this
company blue chew love the listeners of
the wild ride podcast because they're
ready to hook you up with an entire
month's simply
supply absolutely for free
yeah
seriously like an average month supplier
well
like
yeah a month of boning basically yeah
and uh
it's awesome you go to bluechew.com you
don't have to even see a doctor to get
the prescription because you can consult
with the medical provider right there on
the website it's fast it's easy and if
you use the promo code stevo like i said
you get an entire month's supply
absolutely for free all you have to pay
is five dollars for shipping
yeah and if you're on the fence about
this wondering
is taking bluetooth tablets a lot of fun
does it give me an extra like raging
boner i can answer that for you yes it's
a lot of fun
lux can answer that for you i second it
it's a lot of fun so go to bluetooth.com
use the promo code stevo
five bucks for shipping whole month for
free now let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen big j okerson
hell yeah yeah dude
the first podcast that i've done without
either scott randolph or the gorgeous
paul briskey really yeah oh man i hope i
pull my weight
and it's uh also the first podcast
with our new guy tk
what's up tk looks like you don't have a
microphone you stupid smile oh yeah
here's my microphone yeah this [ __ ]
guy goes around whistling all the time
he doesn't even know he's doing it yeah
he just he just whistles it's the
creepiest thing are you a great whistler
i'm a great whistler and i'm very happy
but
it's a problem for some people it says
that i'm angry at him for carrying a
tune in his heart
yeah maybe
too much joy
also i think when someone whistles
especially along with music they really
are trying to let you know they know the
song
okay
he's he's for acapella dude acapella
yeah nothing behind it's a one-man band
a whistle yeah i could beatbox too but
you guys do your thing yeah
i love tk
a very very competent producer and
editor competent yes he's uh
he's an accomplished i thought right
he's a very very there's a job to be
done
and he gets it done
do i like the way he gets it done
not always
son of a [ __ ] it gets done as long as
he doesn't whistle
wendy
he's a very passable producer and editor
but yeah man thank you so much
at this price
thank you so much for doing this too
thank you
what a schmuck i am i've got this uh
this
just obnoxious [ __ ] humongous piece
of [ __ ] rv which i wrapped to in an
attempt to disguise it as a tour bus
and uh of course he can't drive a
big-ass bus into new york city
so i hit you up and said ah man hey dude
can i get you to leave new york city
to go meet me in somewhere in [ __ ]
new jersey
oh this is the [ __ ] hotel strip oh is it
oh no it's borderline it's because some
of them are nice enough they're
considered airport hotels like newark
airport hotels
but for the most part it's
this is yeah get a hook there's probably
some lot lizards hanging out in these
places jersey lot lizards yeah still
have bangs
if it wasn't bad enough that i made you
drive to new jersey to come
meet me then when you get here i see you
down and inundate you with over an hour
of video of me performing stand up i
enjoyed every second of that that that
special was great
what thanks wild things you're willing
to do
yeah it's uh it's fun man it's not even
a special that's just uh you know what
i'm touring with now
and i i could not be more grateful for
you to have sat down and watched it oh
man absolutely
you and i did stand up together for the
first time
almost 12 years ago yeah yeah caroline's
comedy club yeah steve owen friends it
was me will uh will sylvans and i can't
remember who's the third person uh gina
wisconsin
yeah yeah yeah
i think gino doesn't believe in covet
now oh yeah i think cheeto's going full
conspiracy theory well uh the covet is
over isn't it
uh by all accounts i think
i mean i'd like to hope so yeah i flew
in between trips i did a uh
i did the nashville festival last week
i did a kid rock kid rock comedy jam oh
are you serious did you rock to comedy
he did yeah so he did more just hosted
and did like uh like a joke or two here
and there told a story here wow
it was pretty neat came out of pim in a
pimp uh
cape you know the big fur coat and
everything so we did all the kid rock
stuff
he really uh
did hilarious i was so excited because
we're supposed to do the kid rock
comedy jam at the ryman auditorium where
he
was hosting a stand-up show and then
afterwards to go over to kid rock's
honky tonk his bar
where
he was going to be part of the goddamn
comedy jam have you ever done that with
uh joshua myers i have i never want to
do it again no not that it's a bad it's
a great form of of comedy it's a great
uh show
i i just i'm not i'm not much for
singing no i don't know i love it so
much i have so much fun doing that show
but uh that was happening at kid rocks
bar afterwards so we all did the comedy
show and we all migrated over to kid
rocks bar
and like
i was so excited first of all i had to
be talked out of for weeks to not do a
kid rock song at the comedy jam because
they were like he's not gonna like that
and i was like all right so then uh
i picked my song i was gonna do and we
went
to the comic gym kid rock hung out
for 40 minutes tops
and was gone and the rest of the night
was just a let down you're like oh i
thought we were going to be doing this
with kid rock and he split but it makes
sense he should have split was it his
place he was over it i mean he should
have uh
waited and come for the last 40 minutes
right be there at the end yeah yeah he's
oh i've been here the whole time no he
hung in the back and then i kept uh
i was really remind me of looking like
down the street from my dad's headlights
when i was younger like this is probably
him no not him
oh there this one's probably not because
i
when i first thought he left
just based off the way this person was
dressed like way across the room i was
like oh no he's still here as kid rock
was wearing a trucker hat he had two
braids in his hair and he was wearing
like uh
like a softball t-shirt kind of thing
yeah and
i stared at a guy
telling everybody who'd come over i go
relax everyone kid rock's still here
it's that guy over there and
one other people believed it and then
that guy made his way over
he was just some guy who was a fan of
ours like
a big and i thought i realized what it
was across the room i thought he had a
sports spec glasses it was so the
opposite of kid rock of how nerdy this
guy was
that the things i thought were his cool
braids we're just his dangling glasses
around like the
you know like a camouflage
like duck hunters thing it was in
i like kid rock
his music and stuff i mean i don't know
if i care that much about his music not
to put it down and anything
for that matter he's the most [ __ ]
talented musician i mean he plays
everything on stage yeah he walks around
the stage and plays every single
instrument it's unbelievable and then
like
one one time where there was a party and
he just barged up and took over the dj
booth and he was just going off and he
the dude is unbelievably talented yeah
yeah i thought we're gonna become best
friends
i was gonna go trumper for him whatever
he wants
to sell out hard
he's always been big on the uh
the republican party i remember like
doing uh
some extracurricular partying with him
for many many hours yeah and uh him just
extolling the virtue of george w bush
who was president at the time oh okay so
he's always been on that well he's from
norvocal now
i mean his new
videos are fantastic yeah you just take
them like tongue-in-cheek they're so
funny
yeah for sure man
um so yeah dude [ __ ] the
the legion of skanks is a big deal
i hope so it's our podcast we started
we've been doing that for like a little
over 10 years now we call it the most
defensive podcast on earth because we
thought that would save us from
persecution but
nope
we thought it was getting away for a
while but no one knew who we were once
the show started to get popular we got
plenty of the hate stuff followed up by
it too okay and some of it is awful yeah
it's really like uh
like like what what's uh offensive about
it
the show oh i don't think it's offensive
at all we just do unless you're corey
feldman unless you're cory phil that's
the bonfire that's my my serious xm show
we've gone the world got you on his
music
yeah i feel i'm not gonna let you
disparage corey feldman on my podcast
oh the guy brought his own girls to the
playboy mansion you know the way you do
he uh
no you know what it is we actually feel
terrible
how much corey feldman
actively again you know when you're
doing especially like podcasting and
radio you're in a studio
so you're just talking
and like just talking to whatever you
know like you feel you're talking to
your buddy almost but people are
listening all over
and i never dreamed in a million years
we get back to him how much we've
laughed at his music
but it did
and we have hours upon hours of it
breaking down his live performances and
everything but uh
he takes his music very seriously so i
said it bums me out every time he gets
mad or there's something someone plays
for us that
was angry about us but i mean he says
some ridiculous things
spies and whatever my favorite thing he
said on your show which i've heard him
say before because i did when his
documentary came out i'm like oh we have
to watch this for sure
we have to watch this
and uh it didn't come out the first
night it was supposed to come out right
it streamed and then it got taken over
the stream but that's what it means like
he comes out now
we've streamed things live
many times on over gas digital and
things like that and you know like it's
not a perfect system things go screwy
and get [ __ ] up sometimes
and that's what happened i'm sure
clearly but instead of just coming out
and be like hey guys wherever from the
stream it's always going to be like he's
like the powers that be are coming
the circle the choppers are surrounding
us everybody we only have moments left
it's like no one can just play the
documentary man right let's go
but uh
you know
it's got to be a hard thing
being such like uh
you know i always think it's an
interesting like
thing that why have you ever met joey
fatone
joey fatone i think is so rad
because
when i uh first i first met him it was
well afterwards you know it was
seven eight years ago maybe not even we
did the impractical jokers cruise ship
together and we've had a couple times
since and uh and [ __ ] but on that
cruise
like
i mean we were smoking pot on my balcony
with some friends
and just like me asking the thing i'm
like isn't that crazy or at some point
uh you know there was tanks driving you
guys you know escorting you guys from
the airport to a hotel in japan
i was like and now you know you're
sitting on
a cruise balcony with me smoking pot
like is that he kind of acknowledges it
and goes like yeah i kind of like that
though that i had that thing and he's
like now i can like you know he has
money to do whatever he wants to do he's
fine and he like
understands and accepts that i don't
know if some people can do i don't know
if some people can kind of go like ah
yeah we're not like right that level
anymore i think corey feldman was like
huge you know i mean at a time like
when he was young
he was huge and i think horrible [ __ ]
probably happened to him in hollywood
for sure but
none of that makes up for that music
you make a good point about
struggling with having been at crazy
heights and that you know and some
people are just okay with it some people
just go with it they just kind of you
know you're able to like
some of you i think they have an end
game in entertainment too you know it's
like let me make the money i can make
and then when i'm older who right who
needs that anymore you know but i think
he's been
you know corey fellman interesting thing
he was a-list for sure at a point and
then he went to like
it kind of immediately became laughable
and then he sort of had a resurgence
but i think he thought the resurgence
was everyone's like oh we know this guy
can sing they put him on that they raked
him over the coals on that today show
performance
now before this goes any further i feel
strongly about reiterating and
reinforcing my eternal support for my
bro corey feldman okay period i love the
guy he's my friend okay i consider him
to be very smooth
just like my face because dude i use
harry's products and i gotta tell you
about them it's like the highest quality
five blade razor that you can get i mean
there is no better razor and they're so
affordable plus they're gonna hook you
up with the starter kit which is
everything that you need and it comes
with a weighted ergonomic handle a five
blade razor a killer travel cover for
the razor and dude
it's a value of 13 bucks which is how
affordable harry's is but they're gonna
give it to you for three bucks because
they love the listeners of the wild ride
podcast all you got to do is go to
harry's dot-com
stevo
and
for three bucks you're gonna get this
killer weighted ergonomic handle five
blade razor travel cover comes with
foaming gel
i mean dude
i don't go anywhere without it man and
neither should you and you should
support the podcast right now by jumping
on this killer deal by going to
harrys.com
stevo okay now we can talk about the
legendary today show performance
because he went out there and
dressed like assassins creed and did
christ knows what you want to call that
performance it was wild with a bunch of
teen runaways standing behind him
and then uh
and then he was like
everyone you know made fun of it and he
was like everyone said the same
right right right of course that was
great on your show too he's like how can
everybody have had the same hatred
towards it it's impossible
it's not
but uh
but then they brought it when they
brought him back because it was like oh
you know you can almost hear them when
he's like you know i'm gonna come back
on and play another song and they were
like oh
they're like holy [ __ ] dude he's gonna
do it yeah yeah dude sure get back on
here and he's like that's why they had
to bring us back it was the most viral
we watched video ever and it's like i
don't think he gets it like they're
laughing at you yeah they are they're
laughing at him i think that's almost
like
shitty
we're also doing it
but i also more that like he doesn't
like something in his world presses him
forward to just be like now this is
important versus being like
also you know i've never like uh you
know johnny depp he's in the news so
much now
always kind of fancied himself more of a
musician but he just kept a-list acting
do you know what i mean like in his mind
he's like i'm more of a musician than a
was like sure i guess but like
he's an actor you know i mean right he
was a well another one uh billy bob
thornton
he got made on the radio yeah you're not
allowed to talk about his movies because
he's a musician
oh i heard that was something that was
like uh
i think maynard from uh tool did a tour
around where he was like he's like just
the wine stuff he goes are you [ __ ]
[ __ ] me
i don't okay i have one question
what's with the wine stuff
you guys are talking to me about
different vintages and stopping
processes like oh dude please talk to me
about tool please guys off to me about
tool oh yeah at least like supposed fur
so yeah yeah give me a perfect circle
just uh you know a little ditty from one
of the old days something crazy happened
with the chinese guy playing guitar
um
yeah i think some people just do yeah
and i think he's a guy just is having a
hard time processing so i think in his
mind he's like
i'm still like hugely famous but it's
like a tabloid fodder now and well i i
fiercely back my homeboy corey philbin
hell yeah me too yeah i back him also
right yeah
you've seen my tweets where i name you
as you've always been very generous and
great to me that bad and i appreciate
that so that means the world to me my
favorite community i've named two people
my favorite comedians you and ian
edwards oh yeah i just did ian did my
storytelling show a moon tower this last
week yeah ian's great
yeah i think i i i love to see that like
you're
you know coming up yeah things the last
couple years have been like good yes
it's the broadcasting has been great
right so how does podcasting
compare to the the series xm radio
no rules in podcasting really what we do
it's all self pretty you know it's
in-house it's our podcast network right
we know we're able to put up or not put
up on youtube so like we give like
pieces of it on youtube but for the most
part it's a
it's a subscription service and we give
them okay i think like the newest 15 are
always free or something
but i always messed those things up
yeah but
it's uh and then sirius is like
serious what i like about the radio is
it's discoverable like people just
driving in their car put on the channel
randomly and like
we come on you know i mean whereas like
podcasting like you have to hear about
it from somewhere i don't think people
just happen upon it
like there's so many stations on sirius
you think people are very few very few
talk comedy talk ones okay in the comedy
thing there's only like uh
it's faction talk is us and they have
comedy central's pretty much gotten rid
of all their talk radio now howard stern
and uh
that's really it
okay
like there's no more just like that and
then news stuff but like if you're gonna
go through like looking for like comedy
[ __ ] like we'll just come up yeah all
right
and um you spend about equal time
doing podcasting in siriusxm
no serious is uh four shows a week
three live and one pre-recorded and then
podcasting is
three shows a week but it's the shorter
they're a little bit shorter uh-huh the
radio has to go like two hours what
what's bringing in more revenue for you
revenue
it's hard to tell because the thing is
like i mean i guess probably sirius xm
but
at the end of the day all this stuff is
and i love it i love i think
broadcasting scratches the same itch as
comedy uh-huh in many ways but like it
seems more like podcasting than comedy
right
yeah yeah but then it but then it comes
like what it's
done for me is the road like people
coming out and seeing the live comedy
that's been like the best thing yeah
because if you're just broadcasting
you better be the best you know i mean
because like there is so much out there
like how do you rise above if you have
no name for it so the the they've all
helped each other is like
me doing stand-up and being able to get
on the road more
right
let people know what i do and that i
have
i'm surprised how many people know me
from just comedy when they come out like
uh they'll be like oh you have a podcast
i'm like yeah i assumed everybody here
was from the podcast or the radio show
that's great and you're like
i see in the
comedy clubs the whole thing like you're
headlining weekends yay i'm all over the
place yeah i've been running around a
ton
lately too i took all those things when
covid was here
and it seemed like everything was
getting canceled anyway what do you mean
you took all those things i took all
these gigs like when covert was here and
he was like i did that all like for the
whole two years they kept offering stuff
like they're going to open in may and
then in may
you could have a week in here and then
may would come and
it wouldn't happen at all so then
eventually though they were like oh
kova's over and then you're like oh i
have 15 weekends in a row i have to go
on the road and they're all over the
place
wow
what was your weirdest show that you did
during the pandemic
oh me and uh
me and david tell did one
some driving [ __ ] the drive-in show
dude i only did one of them and
the thing about my comedy is it's wordy
it's a lot of like long
like intricate bits that have like
several things happening and long
stories
and reference heavy i do the references
because
i thought a lot of comics is advice i'm
like
throw out the most ridiculous references
to pop stuff from your childhood or ever
because
even though
the bulk of the room won't get it
there's always like five people who are
listening and like
like they get it they're laughing and
going they go those people are fans for
life
but you could hear those like 15 10 15
laughs on those things
with the car thing the one at least one
we did
because i've heard it's also blinking
lights sometimes but like linking lights
this one was honking was laughing
and
so daunting every time they'd honk but
even worse was when i'd be like uh what
do you mean daunting it was just like
when they while honking historically in
your mind
something bad's happening right so you
have a thing you know it's like uh
and then i am with [ __ ] all over my face
like hey
sounds like they're mad at you like stop
saying that
stop doing that we go down the road in
this [ __ ] obnoxious
rv wrapped and see whatever
like like it's crazy how many people
honk at the [ __ ] rv oh yeah and and
it feels like they're mad at me yeah
it's jarring and they're just trying to
be like we love you and i can we believe
yeah so it's uh
but the funniest was
i remember i forget exactly what it was
but some kind of weird
i'm like you know and the person looked
like the
the guy who got his throat ripped out by
patrick swayze in roadhouse and just
hear like a car going huh
that blue subaru gets it over there
that guy saw a roadhouse
yeah especially since you're so much
like a
crowdwork guy
nice car people in that car
[Laughter]
they still make hyundai santa fes
yeah it really it was i did one and i
couldn't do it and then a lot of the
outside stuff i didn't really love
either i think people just
it felt like people came
and they didn't feel like they were part
of i think at first everything was great
because everyone was like
we're doing a comedy show now we're
being together you know we're together
again even though we're outside and
we're watching comedy but very quickly
it became just like
people like on their phones most of the
shows just outside didn't feel like they
were supposed to be like paying
attention did this make a big deal right
yeah people start doing rooftop specials
and [ __ ] i'm like what do you stop
embracing this
i said let's let's talk about like uh
celebrities who are celebrities for [ __ ]
other than comedy
oh yeah you were doing comedy now yeah
yeah yeah because because i just
remembered too like uh
when i first got into it and you were
like this is good to me and we worked
together and and you helped me a lot
um
and uh
you know we were talking about uh
about jason ellis doing comedy we love
that yeah
yeah he just worked with me yeah true
sometimes it's the personality though
anyone could jump into comedy
i'm not like i've lost the bitterness of
what that would cause me you know i mean
right i still have my bitternesses but
that is definitely not one of them i'm
like because whatever gets you in the
like my reason for getting into comedy
is no
more noble than somebody else you know i
mean like anyone gets to know it for
whatever reason i just did like younger
that's what it ends up being you're kind
of like well but it's like they did
something else with their life first
right
have you ever done comedy with
have you ever done comedy with jeremy
piven
no
no i haven't cause i've heard positive
things about his comedy really yeah
yeah i don't know i don't know his
comedy at all i mean he's made me i've
loved him in movies and i didn't watch
entourage but like judgement night dude
he was great he was the best character
in judgement night remember that movie
i do not i don't give a [ __ ] about
movies come on dude judgement night that
was do you like you care about music
though
yeah i mean sure i guess
that was the first uh
soundtrack for that was the first thing
that combined
like the rap rock thing the whole album
was like okay cypress hill and sonic
youth together and did you ever do
comedy with uh
ron jeremy
oh i've done things that he was around
he was at the comedy cellar once i think
dennis hoff brought him
and a couple of his girls
and they kind of slid in during the show
i think during dave vettel and like i
would always the comedy seller at the
end of the night was
always like dave attell than me i spent
years going after david tell which was a
great school of comedy
but i think they came in the watch hotel
and ron jeremy has
narcolepsy
he has narcolepsy
and he was in the room
but no one in the audience really knew
he was there at all
and i looked over when i was on stage
that i saw he was asleep i thought it
was going to be awesome that ron jeremy
was there but the next time i got like a
big laugh i got a punchline i was like
everybody that joke was so funny
it murdered ron jeremy yeah and
everyone's uh just going in like first i
get to laugh because like oh this guy
looks like ron jeremy and then the
second burst of like that's [ __ ] ron
jeremy sleeping during the day i hung
out with him many times over the years
and i can absolutely
concur he's got narcolepsy oh yeah isn't
is he in prison right now he's in prison
or he's in jail waiting for his like
sentencing but he's gonna he's gonna get
sentenced like 200 and some years dude
it's so mind-boggling it's wild he looks
like uh like krampus
i didn't know he was
in jail for something for did
crazy like rape accusations like tons of
them outside of work
yeah
i think so and i think also within work
also do you know what he was so
he's a guy that was like
so used to a world
if you if you throw them walk into the
room with like 10
women
varying degrees of attractive
even
the the ugliest one might be like ew ron
jeremy i got such a disgusting awful
thing and the youngest hottest one might
be like i'll [ __ ] suck ron jeremy's
dick to have the story of [ __ ] ron
jeremy you know i mean like uh
and i think he lives in a world where
that approaches him so if you have half
the women that you approach like or guys
coming over like hey my girl wants you
to sucker tits yeah and like he almost
moved when i saw him at least like
zombie-ish to just do these things he's
supposed to do like hey ron this is my
wife and he'd be like titty grab [ __ ]
slap nice to meet you guys
there's like you know like a secret
handshake yeah yeah it was like a frank
sinatra if he was giving nut checks
okay working the room and oh there you
go is that your [ __ ] right there look
at that give a little nipple pull do you
not know that he
like
at least in the past performed stand-up
comedy oh yeah yeah i remember that joe
we used to get he's like uh everyone
says i have a big penis but it's
actually two inches two inches from the
floor he really hasn't got old like a
cat skills
jewish
jewish routine
from the flu
that's so good
i remember i was like yeah i'm bombed
about about all that stuff because i
always liked ron jeremy
and um he was just putting his whole
character even in porn became like a
like
i i saw there was one i saw i don't know
why i like these two but it was like
he like comes in i mean it's all staged
but i mean like he comes into the room
where there these guys are making this
porn with like a new girl or something
and like is it almost like he's like
like checking for a show horse she's
like like let me check her teeth and
almost like but instead of that it's
just coming oh it's nice right like jams
a finger in her and then like squeeze
the base of his old dead wiener and just
like stuffs that tube of toothpaste in
her and you're gonna see her being like
yeah i guess like i guess we're doing
porn it is the thing
what uh what other
celebrities got into comedy
so ti is the newest funniest one for me
because
you just you can't bring
gangster like rap personality to
comedy it doesn't work it's got to all
be like funny and you see the video of
him with the girl
i i remember seeing something on tmz
about it but i don't remember that there
was a i don't remember when i was a girl
said something about like
a legal case he has or something
and he just instead of like laughing it
off and moving she was making a joke
like he gets like mad and he takes the
snags the microphone from her and he
like sits on the stage and makes it very
very
weird and uncomfortable and it's just
like you gotta be able to handle it
what's this that i saw
i saw some clip
of james corden
like berating the guy from star trek
randomly which guy
it was um oh my god
uh
patrick uh stewart patrick stewart
really and he they were up at a podium
at some like award show or something and
he's just berating him james corden like
heckling him or is he like mad at him he
was mad he was mad like yeah james cord
i i
stumbled along uh will smith set the bar
for matt at an award show
got to come you got to bring a flame
flower next time
to that party
that was wild yeah i like i keep getting
click-baited every day that they're like
uh
like chris rock finally speaks out about
the situation and every time
it's a article from the show the night
before he goes he came out and said i'm
all right i'm all right i'm not going to
talk about the slap
and then moves on like every article
said that they go he finally addresses
it but his addressing is always like hey
it happened and that's all and he moves
on completely i uh
how did you feel i'd love to hear your
opinion on what you felt when that
happened
now whatever i say to big j in response
to this
let's be honest the whole world realized
that when will smith slapped chris rock
that we all knew chris rock was about to
make a whole bunch of money off of it
right i mean i just hope the guys got
his website in order with his merch
store to be selling online like anybody
in their right mind would be doing in
this day and age i do it i do really
pretty well with it and the secret to my
operation is ship station what is it
it's a very simple interface which takes
care of all of your shipping needs to
fulfill your orders when you're selling
online it takes every different
way of shipping like ups
fedex like dhl like whatever it is
brings it all into one interface no
matter how you're selling online if it's
amazon etsy your own website brings it
all into one easy interface this is how
i sell everything it's the easiest way
and they hook you up with the best rates
going rates that are normally saved for
fortune 500 companies it's like the
easiest it's the cheapest and if you're
not doing it you're out of your mind
because wake up this is how to make
money in today's world so to get a 60
day free trial with shipstation you're
going to go to shipstation.com
and click the microphone at the top of
the page type in the promo code stevo
and you're off to the races with 60 days
of
free
hassle free
totally easy totally cheap shipping and
i mean dude just if you're not already
doing it start and if you are already
doing it do it more and chris rock that
means you too so one more time
shipstation.com hit the microphone at
the top of the page type in the promo
code stevo and you're off to the races
now let's talk about slaps
i mean
i uh
i don't know that my reaction was any
different than anybody else's um like
whoa
insane
you know like
was that even real and then he's yelling
from his seat
either you realize it was real but then
you see a replay of it and the way he
kind of smiles and smirks as he turns
away
and walks away from having just slapped
like that smirky smile after the like
immediately after the slap yeah straight
took me back to oh it was fake
yeah i don't know i think i think he was
smiling because he was like all right
this bald [ __ ] is probably not gonna
give me any more [ __ ] tonight now from
whatever thing cause they've had to eat
i mean he was eating it all night for
her [ __ ] other people mostly with
that other guy oh they were this is
they're making jokes on him yeah they're
making jokes about that situation yeah
and uh
and then i think he was just you know i
said i feel bad a bit for will smith in
the situation not in this he what he did
was [ __ ] up totally and like against
anything i believe especially with
comedy oh dude that makes me think of
what i really wanted to have you ever
had somebody uh oh the warriors for pa
getting yanked off stage no no
that's what happened when everyone was
like chris rock can you imagine getting
slapped i got yanked off that's eight
foot ten foot high stage where my ankles
were eight foot straight i remember that
like you got hurt
no thank god i was able to like
turn i was just yanking me i was able to
get my second foot like downs he pulled
me off a stool
and uh and i was able to get second foot
down
it was nuts and then lewis came behind
me
and like jumped off stage dragging you
off stage
yeah
i was sitting on a stool like it wasn't
yeah yeah yeah he like pulled me off a
stool like i was flat and i was able to
get my second foot down to like she's
lunged towards him and then lewis jumped
off and like
yeah
kicked out of him which was great oh
louis got the [ __ ] kicked at him for you
or what no no the guy oh no me and louis
were working on him and then the fans
all pulled us off and they were like
don't get in trouble we got it that's
like these guys rule
wow and there was like a whole thing but
that was uh
well yeah i don't think will smith is
any like more correct than
that person you know i mean like that
guy was but at the same time i think
will smith just like
whatever what a weird year man that
thing with that he had to go sit down
and talk to her on the thing yeah can we
talk about anything in private right at
all the red table talk
yeah and by the way i'm all for like uh
laying out the dirty like if so you're
broadcasting man you gotta give it all
and tell them like the shittiest stuff
and your most humiliating stuff you
don't have to but like i've always i
come from the stern school of like
broadcasting with that like lay it all
out there
but like
yeah the process at first i mean he
looks shell shocked and everything she
drags him on to do will smith
and say all right we're going to talk
about me [ __ ] out of the guy he's
like okay
he just has to sit there and kind of
like just and it was good and i loved it
it felt so good he's like
all right i guess
wow
i got to watch that oh it's it's sad
that she intimidates people the funniest
thing on that red table talk i've only
seen the clips of
the big things
but it was snoop dogg
she gets guys so rattled those three the
daughter of her and her mother
at that table snoop dogg you got to
watch this clip it's
him
uh
he's been brought to the table to talk
about his use of the word [ __ ] and
stuff and and degrading women in his
music
and i mean he's dressed like he had to
go to like court i mean he's wearing a
turtleneck he's sitting with his hands
like very proper
and he is just
sandbagging
tupac
and throwing off guard because like you
know she's like and you know snoop with
the with the call people [ __ ] and all
this stuff and he goes yeah you know
it's like uh
you know like tupac we used to talk
about that all the time where at one
point i was like i don't feel like i
should say [ __ ] anymore
and then uh but tupac was like you know
now and then she was like yeah i used to
tell tupac all the time like why do you
gotta use that word all the time and
then snoop dogg goes he goes yeah i know
it's like he'd have those beautiful
songs like dear mama and then the next
song
he's right back to it because snoop
dogg's like saying this like what
but everyone just wants to get it over
with with her i feel like there's like
all right let's just timothy
yeah she is intimidating
dude
she
seems like a real bummer pretty g.i jane
being the thing i always hate that too
sebastian bach walked off
one of my podcasts once
zoom so i guess he turned his camera off
what he did he actually couldn't figure
out how to do it at first which is
pretty funny
pretty funny but it was so ridiculous
like what he got upset for and
and uh he walked off the guy made a gay
joke
about uh rob halford
you know
judas priest and uh
it was again a throwaway
thing i said it was in the moment it was
like we're
getting the [ __ ] with sebastian bach
and he was like the only performer that
doesn't
need to do warm-ups he tells me and
still has such an amazing voice
is the great rob halford and i was like
well maybe she's like gay secrets he
doesn't want to tell you like he gargles
jizz or something
and he was like yo man you could take
that [ __ ] somewhere else and he just was
like
i mean i was just kidding you know
whatever he's like [ __ ] that and then he
turned his camera off but he was still
connected
and then so we all know what just
happened
we all know what he's trying to do but
everyone's crazy all of us is going like
sebastian sebastian
sebastian sebastian sebastian and after
a while he goes i hear you loud and
clear man
and then he just eventually figured out
how to turn it off and went away and
then
rob halford came on the show three weeks
later i told him the story and he was
like he was awesome he just laughed said
it was funny like he didn't care
and uh but it's the same thing like and
then all these because it's like you
know a sebastian bach metal injection
and all these like uh heavy metal
websites started picking it up about how
he like ran and everything from like he
ran out and it's just like they kept
printing the thing and you're like can
you please
stop tying my name to this dumb [ __ ]
it's like it became this big deal over
something i'm like i don't give a [ __ ]
about this joke like if i can go back in
time i just wouldn't have said that i
don't didn't mean anything to me it was
just like a throwaway
thing to say and i think it seemed like
chris rock everything's going to be like
the infamous gi just like he just went
bald head woman
jane basically and it's like that's
going to live forever it's like the joke
that pissed off will smith somebody goes
it's just a bad
throwaway line he had for the oscars to
not curse and whatever he had to get
through you know so bizarre yeah what
was the thing you were gonna you said
i was um
curious because you're a new york comic
and then like in la
i felt like uh
there was almost a divide between new
york comedy and la comedy like around
all the me too stuff because like oh
that's why that's why i figured out it's
not the device somehow very naturally
everybody over here on the east coast
gets called a racist and everyone on the
west coast is a rapist as we go
you got your rapist to the life rape
isn't it right
it's uh
i don't know why it is but it really has
fallen down everybody over here that is
is in trouble for
racist jokes and everybody else
yeah there's like stuff with girls i
just yeah i just noticed that
like
pretty
validly accurately
the new york comics
observed
that
each
la comic that got in trouble in the
metoo thing
like every other la comic just
turned their back on them
like just that that person means nothing
to me right you know like people just
jumped dropping from shows and
stopped working with them and all that
stuff
i mean i don't know it's like new york
we've had that in new york it's
definitely been like uh
it's ari shafir
you know yeah
that like
the kobe thing i didn't think was uh
what bothered me more with the artist
affair was the the burt cried the drug
king burke christian drugged me too i
did same thing with ass i've never taken
acid before in my life oh my god he made
you take acid without knowing in
fairness to him where he might not have
known was going on other people on our
podcast
had the plan to do that to him where me
and uh
one of my other
partners dave smith on that show had
already said very firmly i don't want to
get in the world of that of like dosing
people and stuff i don't want to
play that game
and in fairness to uh
what happened was if you're going to do
it to anybody though it should be ari or
he's the guy you should do like ari
would do it to somebody else so you
could do it to ari and he already's not
gonna get mad he's gonna get upset by it
but r i didn't know was happening
ari
was tipped off that it was happening
so when they put the beer in front of
him that was doze he knew it was there i
have no idea still
but he doesn't know that
he thinks that the podcast is planning
to
dose him you know what i mean so he just
i'm the closest person to him he just
switched his beer with my beer
i drank
a thing about it and then when it was
what's funny was a lot of people the
table didn't know that so when it got
back to me ari
someone says to me goes yeah they do
stari and i'm looking at ari and ari is
in outer space i mean he's looking all
over the place crazy and like
licking his lips and then i'm upset
because i'm like oh man no no no no like
what are we doing guys i don't want to
do this
and then ari's like do what and then
they told him like you know i do you
know they dosed you
you don't acid right now and he was like
oh my god am i he's like or did i know
what was going to happen and switch it
with big j's drink and then me going
[Applause]
wait
no did you really he was like yeah i'm
like no and then i was just bummed for
26 hours awake that's how the rest of
that one i just sat up
that's what everyone was like well did
you at least enjoy it for a little bit
and sink into it i was like no for 26
hours i sat on my couch and was like why
would my friends do that to me i
wouldn't do that to my friends
what are friends anyway
lsd feels like a much more aggressive
dose than molly
um
yeah
yeah yeah but i honest didn't hit me too
too bad actually i just felt like i was
like stoned almost
i didn't i also i'm bad like drugs
i don't i mean i smoke weed every day in
fairness but like uh
like any hard drugs i've taken which
would be basically molly
mushrooms
things like that
i just never like
sunken dmt didn't work for me we tried
dmt and it didn't work did dmt come
along like recently or
i guess and then they last like several
years but like uh everybody else that
did it there same stuff
was like my chick did not enjoy it at
all but like she was like gone for 15
minutes you know whatever it is 10
minutes
i took so much of it it was pretty funny
actually because every i went last
everybody else went already so we'd do a
thing we don't we'd go to my bed and put
them in my bed and
they would take their pulls until they
went down
and then they'd almost get like uh like
hey it's like see on the other side
enjoy the journey it was a very positive
thing everyone was doing like
and we'd leave the room and
they'd go through it or whatever and 10
minutes two minutes later they come out
and be like whoa that was
wild and then i was like then my
girlfriend went
and she went in there she came out of
the bedroom after like four minutes
uh and she was sat down on the bed and
she on the couch
and everyone's looking at her like are
you on it right now and she's like i
don't like this i don't like this she's
like every time i open my eyes i see the
same thing as when they're closed and
there's no and i'm just i don't like
this at all and she's getting upset
and i was like her face i almost didn't
do it because i went all right i go well
it's all right you're here you're here
you're fine just know it's like it's
only been like five minutes and her face
looked at me like it hasn't been a
lifetime and a half so
like she whatever it was it felt like
she was already in it for a while and
then i'm like i don't think i'm gonna do
it but then she popped out of it and as
to
even though she to this day say she
hated it
she didn't want me to not do it because
of her she wanted me to like go through
whatever she went through too so she was
like
when she came back she was like no i'm
fine no it was good no you should do it
it was good and i'm like you said the
time it was really bad like
it was fine you should try it so i went
and took
the same amount everybody else did
and laid back
and they did the uh
like you know it goes all right major
tom we'll see you when you come back to
earth you know they're giving you all
that stuff and i'm like
okay you know i take it and they leave
the room
and i'm sitting there waiting for it to
happen
and uh and i just hear kind of like
snickering and laughing and i look over
the door and i just see like the fingers
of like them like coming to look peeking
on me going through it or whatever and i
was like looking at them like nothing
and then i did double the amount i did
like a whole other like seven polls or
whatever this thing and like i was like
it's just not working at all i was
offered academy i heard you think you
said ketamine i got offered ketamine
recently but i'm also again at 44
am i trying new drugs i couldn't imagine
yeah like wanting to do that like you
know i mean sort of acid it was like oh
you should try it at least i'm like i'm
fine i think like whatever
it's not a hobby you can't but i do uh
also i think with
even when i've done molly over the
quarantine
we did molly a few times and i will say
like
even with mushrooms i've done i'm never
where everybody else is
like i'm nev everybody else is like you
know wrapped in a blanket or smiling or
sweating or the only thing i get mixed
up is like uh i will
talk someone's ear up you know i'll tell
you i'll tell three people at the party
my life story but like
besides that i don't have like the
i've been on mushrooms like my phone
rings i answer it and people are like
how the [ __ ]
you know i don't know it's not like
yeah i don't but i think you have to
submit to them to some degree also like
you have to want them maybe
you got a daughter if i recall yeah yeah
19 though wow it's bizarre i remember uh
like when we started doing comedy you
had like a bit about her and she had
like holes in her underwear yeah yeah
what was that from it was uh i was doing
on stage i did it on
founder if i ever got it on a special or
anything but it was uh yeah she cut
she got holes in her she had [ __ ] stains
in her underwear i guess or you know
like streaks because she was a child
and uh she was embarrassed so she cut
the holes out because she's embarrassed
of shitty panties but not for walking
around in crotchless underwear
it's [ __ ] fantastic
you don't want kids at all huh god no no
the whole idea sucks i mean everything
about it sucks dude i did it young
pretty young i was 23. you mean you did
it by accident oh yeah for sure
for sure how much of the population do
you think
would uh not exist if if
you could only
achieve pregnancy on purpose
oh man it would be thinned out a lot for
sure
yeah this was definitely like it was
definitely like uh she's like i'm
pregnant and i was like
whatever you want to do i'll back it up
like you know let's go
and uh and we did it so yeah i was 23 so
she's 19 now so it is like
i'm surprised when i have friends who
are like uh you know have babies that
are like
37 30 years old i know it's not old at
all but like
i couldn't imagine any other way like
what's great about it now is that she's
19 so right she can come hang at this
point you know yeah i feel like i
already got out of the woods i'm i'm
almost 48. yeah yeah so it's like you're
stuck and it's like yeah you don't want
to be a 65 year old right dad to like a
teenager it's just too much no right and
it's it's like whatever was great about
it you know like i already made it
through yeah yeah you got through with
it but the thing is
i mean now we're through those great
times yeah i just feel it like this
our
parents you know for you and i are the
same generation our parents like
graduating from university meant
like uh
placement in a career of their choosing
and then for our generation and not so
much like very helpful to get a
university diploma but it didn't really
guarantee anything you know
and then for our kids
it's like all right that means
absolutely nothing except just crippling
debt
oh yeah my daughter she said she's going
to go back now but she did the year of
online college
and then came back with like the i don't
think i want to go to college like right
now i don't even know what i want to do
or anything and i was like sweet i'll
stop paying for it like if you're not
sure what you want to do right but i
like that now she's even earlier than i
thought she's saying she wants to go
back which is great
if that's what she wants to do also but
yeah i like i mean just the opportunity
my parents were so bummed i didn't go to
college
my daughter's mother is very bummed that
she stopped going to college but i'm
like
i just want to do something that's all i
care about she likes to write and draw
and she doesn't like she's like more of
a creative so i'm like
do your thing as long as you like
support you know she doesn't
ask for a ton of money i don't like
support her heavy or anything i mean i
would i would but like she doesn't need
me to you know so like she's figuring it
out right i just think that like the
the disparity of wealth in the world
today is just so
just
not it's not cool anymore man like
no do you also worry about
passing i know some people don't want to
have kids or worry about passing on like
bad the bad stuff sure my genetic dna
yeah my dna it's like uh what my dad's
family sicknesses things like that right
my dad said that as far as like
alcoholism and [ __ ] addiction
that uh
it's like playing russian roulette what
they completely loaded gun
it's going to happen yeah
was your dad an alcoholic nah but on my
mom's side of the family everybody was
yeah i just don't like plus i'm like uh
you know the the the world there's no
people in the world that you know
go ahead and help someone who's already
here don't crazy like adoption
yeah
i i would never want it on my conscience
that i created a
person to struggle and [ __ ]
yeah i don't know and i want to [ __ ]
be a kid you know [ __ ] it you know you
also you want to be able to pick up and
do whatever i said like that's
i see that with my friends now they're
like like touring's a much more
difficult thing or they don't want to do
it as much for anything and it's nice to
be like i said i don't have to like be
home to make sure
also where it depends
dictate where you have to live too you
know that's a big thing too a lot of
times
uh with my daughter when she was young
we had to find places that like made
sense for a kid to be you know we
couldn't be like in a ram shackle yeah
[ __ ] hole in the city because it's great
location in the city it was like we had
to live further out for that reason
yeah
i think i stifled my career actually
it's funny my daughter i've told her
this i don't think it's a bad thing is
whatever whatever the way it happened it
happened and that's
i'm happy you know i mean so like it's
i'm fine with however it went but i mean
for sure like when all my friends were
younger it's funny they didn't get it
then
and now i have a hard time getting it
now where i'm like
you know i'm in my 40s and these guys
are close to 40 and i'm like hey let's
do this kind of on a whim thing and
they're like dude i gotta
the kid over tonight to stay in my place
or you know they're doing a family thing
i'm like ah
i'm already done that [ __ ] but i
remember
you know early comedy kind of
the path everyone was pushing was like
oh you do new york and get to go to
clubs you have to go to la and just be
out there like
make three four trips a year and just
kind of get into the clubs out there and
i never
did that i never went to la because it
was just like that's a spending money
trip and i'm like i can only travel when
i was making you know i wasn't doing
that well and it was because having a
kid you couldn't be as broke as
everybody else the time when you're
in comedy starting out supposed to be
the brokest yeah you know i mean like
figuring that out so
that was tough but
bad stories i remember
at least 10 years ago
you said something that was so [ __ ]
funny at that at that uh
caroline's not the carolines at the
vegan restaurant oh yeah and they were
like the waiters was like like oh we
have gluten free and and you were
genuinely confused you were like he said
like
what is what's going on
what is it with this gluten [ __ ] five
years ago nobody ever heard of it now
it's killing
the everybody [ __ ] thing
it was so true too i still don't fully
understand what gluten is it's like
wheat or something i don't know people
can't eat pizza so we got skank fest
coming up in october yeah yeah i i i
don't know why uh we're not supposed to
announce that i'm doing it but
i do believe yeah you are confirmed for
it uh i'm confirmed for it but not for
promotion i mean whatever that even
means but damn i'm [ __ ] stoked dude
it's gonna be amazing skankfest has been
growing every year
it came out we did our first year was
like a 300 person event
at uh at a small off club the creek in
the cave in long island city
queens
and then it went to the brooklyn bazaar
and we started to get that's again we
said before like sometimes the negative
press
as much as it is like it builds like a
positive thing and like the right people
that it matters for and like we had uh
doing in new york for the first couple
years
the access we have i mean gilbert
gottfried's done it pretty much every
year
uh he was supposed to do this next one
dave attel always comes through for you
know i mean it's like these uh
and then
shortly about a year or so after louie
had all his problems louis ck had all
his problems like he was hanging out at
skank fest and he went on and it was
such a cool moment to watch his face it
was really neat
to see him feel like oh man like
everyone's
okay not everyone thinks i'm a piece of
[ __ ] and hates my you know i mean like
they were so inviting them into the
industry i think universally the whole
world
thinks that he got way that his
punishment did not fit the crime the
problem is the whole world isn't as
vocal as like a bunch uh or shooting a
bunch like whatever
handfuls even there are of women who are
i mean the stuff after that i couldn't
imagine
here's the thing i wouldn't be
my own fat guy insecurity has stopped me
from ever thinking i'd have any worry of
being me too like i have much more of a
thing of like a girl
i have more stories of a girl leaving my
room
you know i mean because i was like
played all the youtube clips like a
player laughing and
and then i was like all right well we'll
get you out of here and then being like
you know getting a message later on
myspace or whatever it was back then
like
hey dude like what the [ __ ] were you did
you not want to [ __ ] or something i was
like oh did you want to [ __ ] you should
have made that much more obvious because
i'm terrified to go like so uh and then
you go what are you doing
nothing
so i can't relate to louising
necessarily right do i remember
correctly that he had the
the
common decency to ask like yeah can i
jump off and [ __ ] can't drink my leg
and they'd say like yeah sure
and then you would
and then they were like that's [ __ ] up
and said the power did not very very
very very right that's not the power
dynamic but it's like
i've had like
uh
young comics in my career like open mic
even level comics like wing [ __ ]
because maybe it's because they want to
like
get to know me maybe it's positional or
whatever i don't know you know what i
mean but i've never like i almost think
the positional thing was like there more
like
if i [ __ ]
me and my girlfriend got an offer the
other day i had to explain this girl
gorgeous
she was like oh skankfest thankful sold
out minutes by the way like 3 000
tickets plus and we were like uh
she was like oh i missed out on getting
skank fest tickets i would totally [ __ ]
you and christine
i mean my girlfriend for uh
for skankfest tickets and i'm like we
would love to [ __ ] you but
there's no way i can like i don't have
the ego whatever it is you need more or
less i don't even know
to have to [ __ ] somebody for a thing
you know what i mean like i just never
had that some people i thought i thought
you were gonna say something totally
different what do you think i was gonna
say i thought you're gonna say that like
uh
you know to
have sex outside of my committed
relationship you know
that's fine
this girl was saying this girl was
saying for the both of us anyway she was
like me and christine yeah like i i
don't
i don't know that the
the threesome thing is ever a good idea
no
i think it's a pretty bad idea we
haven't had terrible all right like runs
oh yeah we've been doing this for uh
we've done it for years now i said you
did cool swing air destroyer stuff not
swearing we don't have a couple stuff
but it's like girl like she likes girls
like legitimately right so like
she know but
that said though there's has been like i
said experiments i was like [ __ ]
lucky it's like it does come with its
own set of problems you're right it does
you're not wrong in that like there's
going to be an argument sometime
uh not this person again because
i don't know got a little here there you
know i mean there's been like [ __ ] ups
along the way for sure but for the most
part
it's been uh it's been great so the girl
the offer wasn't crazy that she made
right to me the offer that was crazy was
to go like i
i you know it takes me almost back when
i did the tours with the bands you you
interviewed jonathan davis with corn
yeah
we were on the mayhem fest
uh one year this girl
gorgeous
atlanta i remember she and she was with
a guy
who i was just certain was her boyfriend
i was like yeah this is definitely
her boyfriend
and he told me so quick that he wasn't
her boyfriend he's like oh no we're just
friends man
and then because she was kind of giving
me like uh oh [ __ ] if you want to like
take us backstage
and she was so hot that i was like
blinded by that for a second i was like
yeah and she's like yeah i'd [ __ ] you to
go backstage and he was like if you will
dude
and i was like this guy i'm like
um
i'm like yeah i guess come back stay so
we started walking and when we got to
the fence
to go the actual thing to go backstage
we got there i stopped
and uh i was like um
i'm gonna bring you guys backstage but
like you don't have to [ __ ] me to come
back i was like that moment just felt i
was like because well for one
what are they [ __ ] you for also it
should be it should hold a value of
something
that like in my mind she's like selling
out and just going like i'll let this
gross guy [ __ ] me i don't know it's what
she was she wasn't thinking that cause
we ended up [ __ ] later that night
like well after she was backstage and
doing everything
but like
i get the thing right away i'm like oh
like you're like i was like on this hill
you got to climb to get the thing you're
right and once i feel that way so i was
like yeah i'd rather and also
when you climb that hill
i'd very likely
if the prize on the other end was
fantastic
you'd be like well she's never going to
really even show a face of like this was
awful because she got this thing she
wanted
and i was like backstage at a concert
spoiler alert it's really not that
awesome
it's k you've been on big tours it's
catering
it's
you know i don't even know what you know
so it's food it's not [ __ ] you for a
cheese showers it's like the buses but
most of the bands are just on there but
there's really not anything happening
backstage and that like
they're going to be like oh my god i
can't believe i got to see that right so
i'm like oh you're going to [ __ ] me and
then be like i [ __ ] that fat guy to
watch rahm zombies drum tech build a
drum kit for a half hour
so i have yeah i've like
yeah i was never worried about uh
any of the meters i was surprised i ran
through la those stories but i think
it's also a world
in fairness to those guys i don't i
don't know the truth or not truths about
anybody's thing but like i think what
ran
you know i mean the comedy there's
nothing in new york that has the
equivalent to like
you know people would say all the stuff
of like uh
oh the porn stars every night i mean
from back in the 80s when it was like
you know we interviewed gingerlynn and
uh
christy canyon not long ago classic porn
stars and they were like oh the day is
hanging out you go to the comedy store
and then you go over here and like that
world just does exist there so
do you know what i mean this is a
hungrier like a a hungrier town of like
chicks trying to [ __ ] people who are
important and stuff so i think
these get clouded by it just getting
nailed with it all the time it probably
gets like
uh overwhelmingly [ __ ] up a lot i guess
man
i've never been that good if a hot
chicks want to [ __ ] me i really like i'm
like what's the angle
like i don't know i think you're
attractive and really funny or you're my
favorite comic or something and you're
like yeah but like
you know what i look like under this
dude it's epic um where did you get
dates coming up
yeah i'm all over the place uh this
weekend coming up i'll be in la for
netflix is a joke festival both shows
are sold out though i think we're doing
the i'm headlining the improv one night
yeah yeah it's friday night and then
sunday night at the improv also i'm
doing my storytelling show the worst
which i'd love for you to do sometime
we're at a festival together cool man um
and then after edmonton canada comic
strip yeah and uh which now they put you
up you know that club but you've done
that club a bunch i think
the the comic strip and that's in the
edmonton mall yeah
the water park in it yeah but this is
the first time it's always been a condo
club where you stayed a condo
but now they've i don't know if they got
rid of the condo but now it's i was
always in a hotel there that's connected
to the mall and it's themed rooms
right yeah i've never done it before i'm
excited to go stay in like you know uh
like a pyramids or something whatever
the the thing is so yeah edmonton
phoenix i'm on the road every weekend
bigjaycomedy.com yeah big day comedy.com
phoenix here at stand up live yeah yeah
i love that place too yeah
that was a great place to door in covet
too
they got yeah they got over on people
there because it's like a 400 seat room
and they were doing half capacity but
they count as capacity of copper because
they have the whole place right so they
were able to put all 400 people and
every time i got on stage i was like
this can't be legal
yeah dude [ __ ] gnarly coveted um so
so we already did bigjaycomedy.com yes
sir big j comedy and uh what about like
social media and [ __ ] uh at big j okason
on pretty much everything and then yeah
listen check out legion of skanks
listen to the bonfire on faction talk
103.
this is exciting this is a kick man
yeah i mean it's a piece of [ __ ] rv
we're hanging out on it i love it
the tour bus touring is the dream man i
said i only did i've only done it with
i've made friends on every tour i've
ever done on a tour bus but like for the
most part i've only done it with like
the production crew and stuff like the
idea of like having like three or four
of your buddies yeah on a thing is just
it's the best you wake up and you're
there you're what dude that that's a
i really believe that
[ __ ]
anybody
who's talking about they're on the
comedy club circuit because they love
doing comedy yeah
i'm like
because it's rough too at the airports
and the hotels and the [ __ ] it's
you loved yes it's awful let's say you
get paid you don't get paid for like the
the show the show's fun you get paid for
like
being at a layover at 5 30 in the
morning in minneapolis
45 minutes that's the stuff that's such
a weird job to complain about
but it's pretty it's a lot it's dude
it's no life to live
the comedy club grind is really [ __ ]
gnarly life and then it and then like
the tournament the tour it's like
yes
oh yeah well it's like a solace though
in that regard without without the
flying that does it ruins everything
well at least you have to wear the
[ __ ] stupid mask on the plane anymore
not yet not yet again right yeah
i kept sucking all that [ __ ] too i was
like when they take the mask off in the
airport like that's probably why i
haven't gotten sick for a long time i'm
not gonna wear i'm gonna keep wearing
the mask and they were like you don't
have to wear it i'm like i'm taking this
dumb thing off
this thing [ __ ] sucks yeah it did i
was like still in the airplane but no
not there either but you're you're on
your way up and [ __ ] tour bus
you know we'll get there hell yeah yeah
park our tour buses next to each other
dude i love it man i love it dude i love
you so much man thank you
yeah and then driving in new jersey to
come here and play you know dad like
a a true friend and i owe you one man no
not at all man if there's anything uh if
i can and um if you want to get me on
anything just let me know i will do yeah
yeah we'll have you on bonfire again and
some uh yeah and then dude we had a good
job
when we're at uh
we're a skank fest man you're gonna
you're gonna i i'm so excited
i think you're gonna love the vibe of it
so much it's such a love festival i'm
traveling
what it was we were laughing so [ __ ]
hard on the bonfire show at
see if there was something to do with
like
it was like some chick that was on
instagram live or something and but she
was on there with like a rapper or
something exactly what happened that
girl came to my show in huntsville
alabama
and of course made a problem in the show
and i think got removed
yeah it was little boosie she was sort
of do yeah hey boosie and like yeah i
don't remember what it was she was
trying like she was willing to do
whatever dirty stuff he wanted but she
was a real fan of his he was like you
remember your first album when you had a
guest spot on there from that one rapper
he's like yeah yeah show me your
butthole
and she'd be like uh-huh she'll just do
it and she goes do you think you're
going to do another song with lil tayte
anytime soon sucker one of them titties
for me
uh as your rap stars just kept asking
questions
yeah
what a nitwit i i i remember laughing so
[ __ ] hard today yeah and we gotta do
it again absolutely all right don love
you too man thank you
yeah dude now can i give some love to my
man tk
i mean
he's a
a whistler
he's
you know
like
he's my guy
love tk dude and um
i think tk did a great job so please
everybody i want big j to to
feel the love so let's um
please please let big j wickerson feel
the love and i hope you feel how much
love i have for you my wonderful
glorious street team
for sticking around to the end of the
podcast
and i'm
like totally not kidding about
how
seriously how deeply i boned lux last
night
[Laughter]
so yeah i love you all thank you